there's this expression called level
five klinger
but she was that and i was like ladies i
was like it was not chill
we ask people the same questions at
different periods of time following a
breakup to see how time has shaped their
feelings about the experience
[Music]
my name is gabriel hi my name is dennis
we were together for over two years and
we have been split for
for like a month and a half yeah
month and a half we've been split up for
about a year and a half three years six
and a half years
nine years
in this moment how do you feel
it's kind of weird to just like sit and
like be in my own little space but like
next to him i have to say the same thing
like but i like i feel comfortable as
well because like i've been together for
so long so it's like let's just wear it
together
together a little nervous i guess very
nervous yeah i feel fabulous i get to
share an amazing
moment with an awesome friend
we started dating freshman year of
college so i was kind of just getting
used to being away from my family i had
just dropped out of college i was
failing pretty hard that was just hard
on me mentally i was
in eighth grade i had dated a couple of
girls but
he's kind of the reason why i found out
i was gay i had this really great job i
lived alone and i just really thought
that i was
living the life
my life when i started to date my ex
was
pretty dark
my father passed away
about a year and a half before emma lara
i was also going through a little
rough patch i had a fiance that
passed away a little prior and
we were able to help each other through
that together
he wore a suit to class one day and it
caught my attention
i like went on twitter and i was like if
this gets 50 likes then i'll dm the boy
from my class and i'll tell him i have a
crush on him so i ended up sending him
the tweet
so my friend from high school
was performing on the sunset strip lara
jean was at the bar and i walked up to
the bar to order a beer and then we
started
chatting it up we met on a dating site
this is like my space days and what drew
me to him initially was his looks i
think that
in terms of online dating that's what it
is first sometimes people are like oh
it's not physical but honestly with him
it was like he just looked
very debonair it's his hair
yes
being in love with him i think was
the type of young naive love that
a lot of queer youth specifically
think about
you get to have that romantic experience
that
all the straight kids seem to always get
i felt the most comfortable with you
like it just felt like floating on
cloud9 and we weren't stopping i mean
we had our super high highs and then
like the lows were terrible so
emotional whiplash is like the best term
i can use
our breakup really felt fuzzy to be
honest when you break up with someone i
think the healthiest thing is to have
time apart but we never had any of that
time apart because we literally have a
whole podcast together made it really
hard it was very easy we we had like
friends over to like
be like we broke up
like we're famous or something
he shuts down when he doesn't want to
talk about things i felt like
i would hurt her feelings if i said
something so i always kept to myself i
could just tell that he wanted to be
like we should break up but i knew he
was too scared about my feelings
what's my favorite memory with him
it was specifically one night when we
were in the parking lot of in and out
and uh we are listening to moana and
we're just like singing along together
really loud
i think one of my favorite memories
was that part of like a relationship
where you're like really like being
someone's like family and really getting
to know them
we're doing this okay
um
so
my most pain memory
started with
us
having a fight
because he had been cheating
and
it just ended with him grabbing me by my
hair
and um
essentially dragging me through my from
my kitchen to my living room there were
lots of red flags
he came to my house once and never left
i mean i was 23 in naivas hill
and he was like one of my first
boyfriends
i think the biggest struggle for me in
our relationship was just knowing the
whole time that we were most likely
never going to end up on the same path
or in the same area yeah there's this
expression called level five klinger
but she was that and i was like ladies i
was laughing it was not chill
it was not chill but when we talked
about i was like hey you need to go and
find yourself i need to go and find
myself we had to like fly on our own
paths i decided like it was probably
best for me to move out of phoenix to
the east coast and change my scenery and
do something different the biggest
struggle within the relationship was
leaving
one i thought that that was it that i
was never going to be in another
relationship and i needed to figure out
how to make that work the other thing
was just
lots of manipulation
healing with
our relationship has actually been very
easy for me because we had each other
throughout the whole process yeah
healing from this relationship has
really looked like a lot of
self-acceptance and self-forgiveness
my family my my unit that was there
was the most important for me healing
from this relationship has looked like
healing from
relationships with my parents being the
initial
reasons why
i
was choosing
these types of
relationships to be in in the first
place
i
didn't work out much when we were
together because
she loved me so i felt like i didn't
really have to fix myself so i have been
going to the gym and that's been really
well for me because it's just
trying to find myself and how i can be
better our relationship then was
naive i really didn't know how to love
another person i barely knew how to love
myself
i was a little crazy
[Laughter]
yeah i just didn't know what was going
on what i wanted what i didn't want and
i was
like testing it all out on him and now
i know who i am and i think that's a
huge difference
it just
was a catalyst
for me to learn more about myself that i
am very very strong that i just am
deserving of love she gave me this
perspective on on how to find myself and
that was important because i was lost
looking for it then you gave me the
tools i needed vice versa absolutely
cool yeah
i appreciate lisa being lisa and being
like goofy and funny and just someone
that i can always be myself with
thank you for giving me
like
the love you had for me and just
being great to me
i'm
just so happy that you're in my life
i'm sorry for everything that i did to
you back then
[Music]
oh my god i can't try that because of
you i like
was able to get through everything
that's why i love keeping you around
because you remind me of how much i've
grown
in this moment i would like to tell my
ex thank you
for
being someone
who
showed me
what
i don't need
thank you love you you're my best friend
in the world
and thank you for being in my life
we're such babies
it's gonna be an awkward drive back
we drove together
two hours away
a lot to unpack on the way back